vamos a calcular cuánto tiempo se
encuentra este objeto en el aire si
conocemos su velocidad vertical o la
magnitud de su velocidad vertical que es
ese por seno de teta si su velocidad
vertical es s por seno de teta
qué tanto tiempo va a estar en el aire
bueno si yo les dijera que algo va hacia
arriba a 10 metros por segundo y la
gravedad lo desacelera a 10 metros por
segundo al cuadrado cada segundo se va a
desacelerar 10 metros por segundo
cuánto tiempo le llevará a ese objeto
llegar a cero es decir a dejar de
moverse vamos a dibujarlo por acá
digamos que tengo un objeto que se está
moviendo hacia arriba a 10 metros por
segundo y digamos que la gravedad
la gravedad
lo desacelera
a 10 metros por segundo por segundo así
que cada segundo que pasa se va a ir
deteniendo esto 10 metros por segundo
bueno pues nos tomara exactamente un
segundo para que este objeto quede
inmóvil en el aire para que vaya de 10
metros por segundo a 0 metros por
segundo así que será a cierta altura en
el aire y entonces la gravedad comenzará
a acelerarlo hacia abajo y le tomará
otro segundo ir de 0 metros por segundo
a 10 metros por segundo así que en este
caso el tiempo en el aire va a ser igual
a estos 10 metros por segundo nuestra
velocidad
es metros por segundo entre la
aceleración que es esto diez metros por
segundo al cuadrado y esto multiplicado
por dos
esto es lo que tarda este objeto en ir
de diez metros por segundo a cero en
cierto punto en el aire y le tomará
exactamente la misma cantidad de tiempo
volver de nuevo hacia el suelo así que
es por eso que lo multiplicamos por dos
si el objeto se estuviera moviendo hacia
arriba a 20 metros por segundo
aquí esto de aquí sería 20 metros por
segundo también y la gravedad siguiera
desacelerando lo a 10 metros por segundo
al cuadrado esto quedaría igual nos va a
llevar 2 segundos entonces aquí vamos a
tener que nos va a tomar 2 segundos para
ir de 20 metros por segundo a 0 y
exactamente la misma cantidad de tiempo
otros 2 segundos para ir de 0 a 10
metros por segundo hacia abajo así que
no importa cuál sea nuestra velocidad
hacia arriba el tiempo en el aire va a
ser igual a nuestra velocidad vertical o
nuestra rapidez vertical dividido entre
la aceleración de la gravedad y esa es
la cantidad de tiempo que nos va a
llevar y de este punto a este punto al
llegar a cierta velocidad vertical y
después llegar a cero y regresar hacia
el suelo va a ser la misma cantidad de
tiempo siempre y cuando no haya ninguna
resistencia al aire digamos que es un
problema puro
así que este es el tiempo hacia arriba
el tiempo hacia abajo va a ser igual por
lo que podemos multiplicar esto por 2
ahora ya conocemos cuál es el componente
vertical de nuestro problema es ese seno
de teta y lo podemos sustituir
directamente aquí en la fórmula y
sabemos cuánto tiempo vamos a estar en
el aire el tiempo en el aire va a ser
igual a esto yo creo que primero escribo
el 22 por nuestro componente vertical de
la velocidad s por seno de teta
todo esto dividido entre la aceleración
de la gravedad no pierdan de vista que
este 2 de aquí es el 2 que puse acá si
ustedes me dijeran que estoy lanzando
este objeto a no sé a 100 metros por
segundo
esto sería 100 metros por segundo y si
te está fuera no sé 30 grados
entonces el seno de teta sería un medio
100 metros por segundo por un medio
dividido entre la aceleración de la
gravedad multiplicado por dos y
obtendremos exactamente la cantidad de
tiempo que estará el objeto en el aire
cuánto tiempo le llevará llegar hasta
arriba quedarse un momento quieto aquí y
regresar hacia abajo